Wow
put in the effort you want to make it as
an entrepreneur you got to put in the
effort you need to work for it it's not
going to be easy you're putting your
blood your sweet your tears everything
you got into making this business fly I
recently posted a tweet with a quote
from Mark Cuban and Mark Cuban is a
hustler the guy works hard and his quote
was that I shared there's very little
knowledge that can't be obtained through
effort and I got a tweet back from
Kingston for live for live who wrote can
you explain that to me here's the thing
as entrepreneurs a lot of us have
limiting personal beliefs we think
because I don't know this I'm not going
to have success and Cubans point is
whatever you don't know whatever you
need to find out if you are willing to
put in the time and the effort you can
find an answer if you really want to get
into an industry and you have no
background in it you can go in you can
have massive success but you've got to
work for it anything you need to learn
you can learn if you put in the time the
effort the patient's the hustle to
figure out how to make it work so that's
his point you're not going to have
massive success as a start-up working 40
hours a week if you look at cuban and
how we got started he had huge success
and everything that he touched at the
beginning because he was the hardest
working guy when he was starting off as
an employee he was still the
hardest-working employee when he started
with his various businesses he worked it
harder than any of his competition even
though he had less knowledge getting
into it he became the most knowledgeable
person about that business and people
flocked to him because customers want to
deal with experts and he only got that
knowledge because he put in that time he
put in the effort he hustled he needed
to make this happen so you got to do the
same with your business you have to
commit to it you've got to pour yourself
into it you have to believe that what
you're doing is right that is going to
work out if you put enough heart passion
energy and effort into making it happen
and it's okay even if you're starting
part time
but do something every day to grow this
thing right the goal is that you don't
have to be a part time entrepreneur you
can quit your job and do this full time
and make a huge income and have a huge
impact but it comes from doing something
every single day to move your business
forward even as just a little bit
because as soon as you start giving up
on that as soon as you stop putting any
effort your company dies you have to be
the heartbeat of the business you've got
to pour into it put your full energy put
your full effort love it and you will
have success with your company believe I
hope that helps shed a little light on
that quote I love it and hopefully
inspires you guys too if you guys like
the video thumbs up below love seeing
those come in and I want to hear you
have to think please leave a comment
underneath I want to know what you're
thinking you like the video you have a
question for your company let me know
I'll do a video response thank you guys
will see you soon